i
[Música]
ah
la administración de job aiden dijo que
está elaborando una lista de sanciones
específicas contra miembros clave del
gobierno bielorruso
concretamente james aquí la portavoz de
la casa blanca dijo que su país también
suspenderá un acuerdo del 2019 entre
washington y minsk que permitía usar
mutuamente el espacio aéreo además eeuu
volverá a imponer sanciones de bloqueo
total a nueve empresas estatales el 3 de
junio prohibiendo así que los
estadounidenses negocian con estas
firmas en un comunicado el gobierno de
bailén también le ha pedido a lukashenko
que permita una investigación
internacional creíble sobre los hechos
del 23 de mayo cuando el avión de
pasajeros de ryanair que volaba de
grecia a lituania se vio obligado a
aterrizar en minsk capital bielorrusa
[Música]
la unión europea y de prácticamente
aislar a vela rusas y se decidió en la
última reunión de líderes europeos en
que se prohibió que las compañías
nacionales del país puedan aterrizar en
territorio europeo tampoco se recomienda
las compañías aéreas europeas que
sobrevuelen el espacio de vela rusa
además están preparando nuevas sanciones
económicas especialmente en sectores
clave del país además también se
preparan medidas para altos cargos del
régimen y se mantiene la congelación de
un paquete de ayudas de 3.000 millones
de euros en inversiones la unión europea
confía que con toda esta presión
diplomática y con estas medidas
minsk reacciones pero también preocupa
el acercamiento del presidente alexander
lukashenko al presente ruso vladimir
putin por lo que podría provocar todo
esto un efecto contrario y que a pesar
de las medidas de la rush continúe con
su deriva autoritaria
[Música]
la unión europea eeuu y otros países
occidentales condenaron el desvío del
avión en el que viajaba el disidente
bielorruso romano protosevich y
exigieron a mick que le pusiese en
libertad junto a otros detenidos ahora
los líderes europeos han estado incluso
a cerrar el espacio aéreo de la unión
europea para los aviones de los rusos y
también están dispuestos a vetar los
vuelos internacionales sobre bielorrusia
así que los gobiernos de mills y moscú
están trabajando ahora en una reacción
conjunta a las sanciones occidentales
así lo ha anunciado el presidente
bielorruso alexandr lukashenko que lleva
gobernando su país desde el año 1994
bielorrusia se prepara para encajar una
nueva ronda de sanciones occidentales y
ante el aumento de la presión
internacional el principal apoyo de
lukashenko vuelve a hacer una vez más
rusia rusia es el principal proveedor de
petróleo y gas para bielorrusia pero las
reexportaciones de los diarios rusos de
crudo procesado y de petróleo son uno de
los principales ingresos de mick y ahí
sí que pueden hacer daño las sanciones
[Música]